toutes les infos vous font réagir mais
celle ci particulièrement je le sais
dans le 12 45 de m6 on a découvert la
dernière initiative une association de
protection des animaux et je sais que ça
va pas vous laisser indifférent
si la rouille au fromage à caen devenait
la rue au fromage la péta milite pour
des noms de rues vegan rebaptisé la
place de la grande boucherie à
strasbourg place du potager et la rue du
jambon à lille rue des jambons alors rue
du jambon qui devient rue des gens bon
qu'est ce qu'on en pense
c'est complètement stupide salaire qui
est de la prochaine étape c'est la rue
de la soif à paris on va la transformer
en la rue de lappe a soif ou la ville de
monbazillac on va la changer
on ne sait pas le du robinet face à
l'abm et bien sûr que si à un moment
donné il faut arrêter cette espèce de
militantisme à la con je suis désolé
c'est ouais ça me ça vous énerve grands
chevaux c'est tout à fait très bien
d'accord qu'est ce qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous qu'à trouver ce que vous
semblez plutôt l'inversé total des
milliers moi je je je je trouve pas du
tout ça idiot je trouve que même mois
par mois ça me précède habitait rue de
la grande boucherie je précise au lit
plus poétique et jgc mec j'ai tendance à
vous mais ça peut être aurait il dû
poser maintenant je m'interroge c'est
des gens qui ont une vision un petit peu
différente de celle de la masse des
français donc forcément ils sont obligés
pour ce pour exister et faire des
actions pour l'imposer de faire des
choses qui parfois sortent un peu de
l'ordinaire et surprennent mais moi
j'aurai toujours plus tendance à les
défendre eux que d'autres donc voilà à
fond vim
les vegan ccc c'est un peu de la com
c'est un peu un coup de buzz mais
franchement ça me semble ça vous choque
ça bougera pas plus sympathique
c'est insupportable ces gens comme ça
qui arrive qui nous donne des leçons
comme ça et et ça continue opération
coup de poing par ci par là
moi j'ai écouté les conseils du bon
docteur jimmy mohamed qui nous dit ne
pas manger trop de viande mais quand je
vois autant d'opérations vegan comme ça
à tous les trois jours on en parle dans
l'émission j'ai envie de manger de la
viande est encore plus alors merci à
elle et bien vous allez avoir quelques
petits tours sur twitter
mais oui est ce que vous en pensez vous
aussi est-ce que vous pensez que
l'action dé vegan cube essentiellement
basés par beaucoup sur la communication
voire le coup de com est-ce que c'est
too much parfois est-ce que y'a du
prosélytisme
je pense que c'est de la communication
de niveaux de fond de cuvette
la wii a très bien voir c'est d'aller
vers des années bien sûr c'est comme
l'écriture inclusif c'est absolument
insupportable je me souviens d'une
polémique on parlait des journées du
patrimoine on voulait renommée ça en
journée du matrimoine demain nous
n'accoucheront plus à la maternité mais
la paternité
tout ça c'est des combats complètement
futile et inutile qui nous font perdre
la vraie idée c'est la maltraitance
animale
le fait que des animaux ne sont pas
considérés et ne sont pas abattus
correctement la wii que nous consommons
mal mes fessiers j'enlève egan qui vous
disent ça passe aussi par une prise de
conscience mais c'est fatigant ce genre
d'école inique inutile quotidienne notre
pays a déjà énormément de problèmes
j'essaie d'en résoudre pas mal pensé
arriver avant la fin du quinquennat
mais la cctv vous n'avez pas placer anne
hidalgo dans l'argumentaire on peut
s'arranger je peux me présenter à
réfléchir à une amicale pour sauver les
parisiens mais aussi la france car c'est
la france souffre on a besoin diamant et
à la politique de répression de la
mairie tel que paris qui a virgin
c'est l'ensemble des préfets